well today the Clark County School
District Board of Trustees held its
first board meeting since its new
members were sworn in one teacher used
that opportunity to speak on how staff
are leaving due to an increase of
behavior issues among students Joshua
peguero was at that meeting joins us
live from the Greer education center
with more here's Joshua
that comment was brought up during the
public comments section of the meeting
that took place behind me Vicki cridle
the president of the Nevada Education
Association of Southern Nevada says CCSD
needs to increase the number of social
workers available at schools
at my school we have one counselor for
over 700 students
he does absolutely amazing work but one
is just not enough Vicki cridow teaches
reading to elementary students she says
behavioral issues have increases the
pandemic and it's impacting student
achievement many educators are telling
me they don't feel safe at work
there have been several high-profile
incidents of violence and many many
others that are kept quiet on Wednesday
student at Sandy Valley High School was
arrested after threatening a staff
member according to the principal last
month two Legacy High School staff
members were injured trying to break up
a fight that led to the arrest of three
juveniles we've previously reported on
another assault at Legacy back in
February when a student attacked the
school secretary in April of last year
three schools Foothill High School Grant
Sawyer Middle School and Palo Verde High
School had incidents of Violence by
students against teachers and also that
same month a teacher at El Dorado High
School was found unconscious in a
classroom after a student allegedly
assaulted her safety concerns regarding
student behaviors fall high on the list
of why people leave and are leaving we
must address these concerns or we will
lose even more
now the district is taking steps to
address the mental health problem and
that includes partnering with Nevada
State College reporting live at the
Greer education center near Flamingo and
Eastern Joshua 8 News Now